maternité tout est organisé pour qu'il y
ait un maximum de sécurité
pour le docteur natalia gontcharova la
directrice pas question de quitter
l'hôpital ni de fuir à l'étranger depuis
le début de la guerre il vit ici
vingt-quatre heures sur vingt-quatre et
ne pense qu'à ses patientes
tout est fermé ici pas de lumière qui
vient de l'extérieur on peut opérer en
toute sécurité
il y a même une sortie d'urgence pour
accéder à un endroit protégé
entre deux sirènes cette maman a donné
naissance à son premier enfant mais
celles qui préoccupent la gynécologue
c'est svetlana qui risquent d'accoucher
avant terme tant elle est angoissée par
la situation tout ira bien nous sommes
des filles on est forte on va y arriver
le pays est avec nous ça va aller
comment vous vivez tous ces moments avec
les sirènes avec le bruit des
bombardements
c'est difficile de trouver les mots pour
expliquer quelque chose d'inhumain
j'essaye de retenir mes émotions mais je
n'y arrive pas toujours
une jeune femme via d'être transféré en
urgence au bloc pour une césarienne des
gestes sûrs dans le calme même avec les
coups des co ba
c'est un petit garçon
prénommé ta race comme l'un des plus
grands poètes d'ukrainiens
pour l'équipe c'est une naissance
particulièrement émouvante le lendemain
du bombardement d'une maternité dans le
sud du pays
comment vous l'avez vécu et vous c'est
terrible une catastrophe une tragédie
pour nous tous
dans quelques heures la jeune maman va
rejoindre l'abri car la nuit la guerre
gronde toujours plus fort
parmi ces femmes certaines ont accouché
dans le sous sol de cette maternité de
café c'est la même chose dans plusieurs
villes du pays
la plupart souhaitent dès que possible
pour la sécurité et l'avenir de leurs
enfants